la terre et la planète de l'eau
ses habitants les humains comme les
animaux ne peuvent vivre sans eau
notre vie quotidienne toute la
civilisation humaine serait impossible
sans elle les êtres se sont toujours
installées près d'elle de nos jours la
majorité de la population de la terre
vit au bord des fleuves mers et océans
pendant des millénaires les gigantesques
ressources en eau de la planète ont été
plus que suffisante pour subvenir à nos
besoins
[Musique]
l'homme n'a jamais pensé à la nécessité
de gérer judicieusement ses ressources
avant le milieu du xxème siècle à mesure
que la population augmente la demande en
eau devient de plus en plus importante
il ya 60 ans une personne sur quatre
n'avait pas assez d'eau pour vivre
confortablement
aujourd'hui une personne sur trois
l'onu estime qu'en 2050 un être humain
sur deux sera confronté à des pénuries
d'eau
la situation s'aggrave
[Musique]
nour qui m'a 40 ans il vit à jakarta la
plus grande ville d'indonésie
il est né et a grandi ici il est
impossible d'imaginer sa vie sans eau
mais vivre au bord de l'eau devient de
plus en plus dangereux
jallet cette mosquée il ya longtemps
dans les années 80 le niveau de la mer
n'était pas aussi élevé il y avait des
maisons là bas des gens qui vivaient la
partie côtière de jakarta est passé sous
l'eau au début du siècle
aujourd'hui toute la capitale
indonésienne risquent d'être inondées
mais un quartier l'est en particulier
il s'agit de loueur à barreaux situé
dans le nord de la capitale est
historiquement habité par des pêcheurs
tous les pêcheurs savent que c'est la
loi de la nature
le niveau de l'eau monte tous les cinq
ans c'est comme ça depuis des temps
immémoriaux
mais les temps immémoriaux des humains
ne sont qu'une courte période de
l'histoire de la planète
le changement climatique enregistré dans
les années 1800 s'est fait encore plus
évident dans la seconde moitié du 20e
siècle
notre planète change les régions humides
deviennent encore plus humide les
régions sèches sont de plus en plus
arides partout dans le monde
l'accès à l'eau potable est de plus en
plus problématique les scientifiques
disent que le changement climatique
l'explosion démographique et
l'exploitation à grande échelle des
ressources naturelles ou en vers un
nouveau chapitre dans l'histoire de la
terre l'anthropocène le naufrage de
jakarta est un symbole de l'impact
considérable des activités humaines sur
l'environnement
nous avons construit notre maison sur
des pilotis spéciaux il y avait beaucoup
d'espacés en dessous les enfants y jouer
il y avait assez de place pour installer
une balançoire
mais au fil du temps année après année
l'eau s'est rapproché nous avons dû
surélever la maison pour la maintenir au
dessus de l'eau nous faisons ce genre de
travaux tous les cinq ans
nour qui m'a déjà dû surélevé sa maison
quatre fois la dernière fois c'était il
ya quelques années ils achètent des
poteaux en bambou usagers s'installe
dans une pièce et rallongent les pilotis
sous une autre quand il a fini une pièce
il passe à la suivante
de cette façon en quelques semaines oui
surélève toute la maison de 50 cm là les
inondations sont fréquentes par ici
chaque fois qu'il ya une grande marée
que l'eau atteint un certain niveau nous
nous retrouvons inondé depuis quelques
heures plus tard le recul et nous devons
nettoyer nos maisons
les enfants tombent souvent malades ou
se blesse lors des inondations alors
mais jusqu'à présent un seul enfant en
est mort
mon mari était au travail et mes trois
enfants étaient à l'école
tout d'un coup il ya eu une inondation
une très forte inondation les gens dans
la rue criaient sortez de vos maisons
c'est une inondation les vagues étaient
vraiment hot et je ne pouvais aller
nulle part
je suis resté à la maison et j'ai
attendu mon mari qui devaient rentrer du
travail vers midi rina 44 ans c'est une
voisine du pêcheur nour kim elle tire
une sorte de café les habitants ils
achètent de la nourriture
lorsque cette inondation a frappé elle
était enceinte de sept mois
[Applaudissements]
l'eau était à peu près à cette hauteur
là mais je suis monté sur le toit quand
mon mari est arrivé il m'a porté dans
ses bras j'ai été trompé mon mari m'a
amené à l'hôpital où j'ai été prise en
charge
j'avais peur que le travail commence
après avoir examiné le médecin m'a
interdit de rentrer chez moi j'ai été
opéré le jour même my high times a eu
des jumeaux ils ont grandi vont
aujourd'hui à l'école à la place d'une
cabane en bois délabré le mari de rennes
a construit une maison en pierre où elle
vit avec sa famille jusqu'à présent
reina ne veut pas déménager car elle a
grandi ici et s'ils vendent leur maison
il est peu probable qu'il puisse se
permettre d'en acheter une meilleure oui
c'est dangereux
tout le monde le dit mais je vise ici
depuis mon enfance et je me suis habitué
même si toutes sortes de malheur se
produisent ici comme les tsunamis par
exemple tout récemment on nous a dit de
quitter les lieux immédiatement car il
prévoyait un tsunami
heureusement il n'y en a pas eu
il y à un puits dans la chambre de rayna
un simple trou dans le sol l'eau mouillé
ça les rails nadeau acheté à la fois de
l'eau traitée et de l'eau potable un
terme à émerger à l'ère de
l'anthropocène le stress hydrique loup
est rare pour tout le monde
pour les pêcheurs vivant sur l'eau comme
pour leurs voisins dont les maisons sont
construites sur le sol
ce point de vente d'eau à mieux à baru
est gérée par sa cour il a 22 ans
ils revendent l'eau de source qui la
porte de la campagne le prix est de 5000
roupies pour une jarre de 19 litres pour
moins d'un euro vous pouvez acheter plus
de 50 litres d'eau
[Musique]
si on fait la comparaison l'eau
souterraine et à moins cher et l'eau des
robinets public est plus cher
jakarta ville de 10 millions d'habitants
n'a pas de système centralisé
d'approvisionnement en eau certaines
personnes comme nord kim irina achète de
l'authie viennent d'ailleurs les
propriétaires du ciné de grands
bâtiments creusent des puits pour
accéder à l'eau douce du sous sol voilà
comment ça marche dans les nouveaux
gratte ciel construits à l'extrémité
nord de djakarta à côté d'un bidonville
à l'heure actuelle nous sommes
confrontés à deux problèmes insolubles
d'un côté nous avons un besoin urgent de
bâtiments résidentiels et brûlant des
bateaux mais d'un autre côté nous
constatons que ce territoire ne convient
pas pour le développement urbain
malgré ce cas il est très risqué d'y
construire en raison de défis bien connu
l'intercom l'élévation du niveau de la
mer ou l'affaissement des gens qui
résident court donc un risque élevé
les pénuries en eau potable sont un
problème auquel font face beaucoup de
villes dans le monde entier
sao paulo le cap
new delhi mexico los angeles la seule
chose qui distingue jakarta et la
quantité d'autres problèmes
environnementaux les problèmes d'eau se
conjugue au changement climatique et à
la pollution par les ordures jakarta est
un modèle réduit de notre planète
une minorité riche pense que tout va
bien mais de plus en plus d'habitants
font face à de graves problèmes
actuellement jakarta ne peut pas se
procurer suffisamment d'eau pour
subvenir aux besoins de la ville la
raison est que 13 rivières d'eau douce
qui pourrait fournir suffisamment d'eau
potable jackass cas sont actuellement
gravement
nous ne pouvons les nettoyer que en
association avec les personnes qui
vivent à proximité directe de ces
rivières
[Musique]
jakarta doit obtenir son nom de la
campagne en une journée
ridouane chauffeur ne fait pas plus de
trois allers retours il faut compter
plusieurs heures de route pour chaque
trajet
redouane doute qu'un jour il n'est plus
de travail que les rivières soit nettoyé
que les habitants des banlieues cesse de
polluer
il n'en a rien à faire ils s'en fichent
et guan vit également dans une banlieue
de jakarta comme tout le monde il
obtient de l'eau traitée dupuis et boit
de l'eau en bouteille tout comme les
habitants pauvres du quartier du moulin
rue le plus grand problème c'est que le
gouvernement ne travaille pas pour le
bien de tous ils ne prennent en
considération que les intérêts des
citoyens des classes moyennes et
supérieures
il se moque du fait que l'affaissement
du sol affectent d'abord les pauvres
on dort pas
[Musique]
l'ingénieur peter le titre a étudié en
détail les problèmes d'eau de jakarta il
en est convaincu
cette immense ville est en train de
couler à cause de l'utilisation continue
et mal géré des eaux souterraines
jakarta est en danger non pas parce que
le niveau de la mer monte
mais parce que la terre sur laquelle
repose la ville continue de s'affaisser
depuis les années 70 nous constatons que
les problèmes ne font que s'exacerber
les inondations sont devenues de plus en
plus grave et cela est lié à
l'affaissement du sol cela signifie que
le nord de djakarta passe
progressivement sous l'eau cela est dû à
la croissance démographique et au
développement industriel la demande en
eau a considérablement augmenté la
population de jakarta a doublé en un an
c'est pourquoi le problème de l'eau est
devenu si important
l'élévation du niveau de la mer dont
tout le monde a entendu parler et
presque imperceptible à jakarta le
niveau de l'eau n'augmentent que de 8
millimètres par an mais le sol s'enfonce
jusqu'à 20 cm par an ce mur a récemment
été surélevée de 20 à 30 cm
car il n'y a pas longtemps en décembre
2017 l'eau est passée au dessus du
barrage le mur construit en 2007
mesurait deux mètres de haut et est dix
ans plus tard ils n'étaient pas assez
haut pour protéger la ville jakarta
détient un triste record parmi les
villes en train de couler jusqu'à 40% de
la métropole est actuellement en dessous
du niveau de la mer construire un
système de pompage des eaux ne suffit
pas il faut modifier la législation tous
les puits creusés illégalement qui
abondent à jakarta doivent être fermés
il y à plus de 3000 ou 4000 puis
enregistrer et le nombre de puits
illégaux est encore plus important car
dans l'ebit cela pourrait être contrôlée
non seulement avec des sanctions mais en
sensibilisant le public les gens qui
travaillent dans diverses industries
après tout il est impossible d'inspecter
chaque bâtiment
le problème ne peut être résolu que si
les gens commencent à penser à l'avenir
de la ville en 2010 9
les autorités ont décidé de déplacer la
capitale jakarta
grosse ville ont disparu sous l'eau dans
l'histoire de l'humanité mais jakarta et
la première métropole qui pourraient
être emportés vers une tombe aquatique
non pas à cause de la nature mais à
cause de ses propres habitants la
première mais probablement pas la
dernière
les eaux souterraines le cycle de l'eau
ce sont de vrais enjeux d'aujourd'hui
nous sommes déjà à mi-chemin de la
limite imposée par la nature sur wii
nous devons sérieusement réfléchir à la
façon dont nous gérons les ressources en
eaux souterraines et comment faire un
bon usage de ces ressources à l'échelle
mondiale la france
les problèmes de l'anthropocène ne se
limite pas au stress hydrique
l'atmosphère se réchauffe à cause des
émissions excessives
la terre est jonchée de déchets qui
finissent dans les océans
cette nouvelle réalité créée par l'homme
transforme notre planète
un nouveau système terrestre est en
train d'émerger
l'état de notre terre s'est radicalement
détériorer nous sommes témoin du
réchauffement climatique
évidemment ce phénomène est causé par
l'activité humaine
janick de nouvelles substances pénètre
dans le sol
azote et nitrates se retrouvent dans les
eaux souterraines et dans les océans not
going to do si grande quantité d'oxygène
sont consommés ou sorte que la quantité
d'oxygène se trouvant dans les océans
diminuent et nous ne savons pas
exactement comment la planète va réagir
la planète réagi à notre utilisation
déraisonnable de l'eau de manière on ne
peut plus claire des plans d'eau
disparaissent les uns après les autres
ce qui était autrefois la merde aral à
la frontière entre le kazakhstan et
l'ouzbékistan
est connu de nos jours sous le nom du
désert d'aragon la superficie du lac
tchad en afrique centrale a diminué de
95 pour cent cinquante ans
[Musique]
l'acs propos situé dans les andes
boliviennes à une altitude d'environ
3600 mètres ne peut plus être trouvée
que sur les anciennes cartes à partir de
2016 tous les kits de voyage disent que
la pop au a disparu le lac ce sécher
également dans le passé quand j'étais
jeune
en 96 et en 1999 il ou réapparaissez et
les choses revenaient à la normale
il y avait des poissons dans le lac le
lac a commencé à s'assécher et il n'ya
plus de poisson depuis cette scène les
flamands vivent ici ils viennent tous
les ans
[Musique]
quand le lac était encore lieu de vie
une tribu de pêcheurs appelé uru vivait
sur ses rives leurs voisins les appelait
les gens du lac
donc on a fait un bond de nos ancêtres
vivaient sur des radeaux 20 il ne
naviguait pas en bateau comme nous
faisons de nos jours il ne mangeait pas
de riz ou de quinoa il ne connaissait
pas ces cultures noté m
il mangeait tous que le lac pouvait leur
offrir
combien tous que le lac leur offrez été
prononcé l'agrément
ils ont mangé des halles du poisson des
flamands et des canards aujourd'hui ce
qu'on appelait autrefois les gens du lac
environ un millier de personnes vivent
dans des villages près de l'ancien lac
comme beaucoup d'habitants de la
lointaine jakarta les gens du lac
étaient des pêcheurs
nous sommes tous pêcheurs depuis notre
naissance
moi aussi je suis pêcheur mon père m'a
appris à pêcher nous allions à la pêche
ensemble
j'étais son assistant nous sommes
habitués à faire ça depuis notre enfance
nous sommes habitués à la pêche à pascal
mais aujourd'hui le lac s'assèche et
c'est une triste époque tournus où
irions-nous toute notre existence est
organisée autour du poisson ancien des
résistants
[Musique]
propos étaient autrefois le deuxième
plus grand lac d'amérique du sud après
le lac titicaca
il y avait une superficie de plus de
2500 kilomètres carrés il faisait plus
de 5 mètres de profondeur ce qui reste
de cela que j'ai en ressemble
aujourd'hui plutôt à un marécage
il ya plusieurs responsables de la mort
du lac
l'étain le zinc le tungstène sont
extraits à proximité du lac depuis des
siècles pendant des années des
particules de ces mines ont terminé dans
le lac en raison du traitement
incompétents des cultures de la terre
s'est retrouvé au fond du lac
c'est ainsi que pau hbos a perdu de sa
profondeur et à comment campagne stop
sera patient bordent le lac ressembler à
une grande et profonde cuvette niépce
brillamment par k o
c'est maintenant une assiette plate qui
recueille toutes les ordures des
rivières si heureusement
mais en dehors des facteurs locaux il y
a le contexte global
le réchauffement climatique fait que
l'eau du lac s'évapore plus vite et
provoque des sécheresses de plus en plus
fréquentes
il va sans dire que le changement
climatique mondial aggravera les
problèmes d'eau dans certaines régions
les problèmes menant à une telle soif
sont principalement causés par
l'activité humaine sur l'impact de
l'homme sur le cycle hydrologique et
l'accessibilité des sources d'eau douce
d'astous pastis est beaucoup plus
important que tous les bouleversements
mondiaux auxquels nous avons assisté
jusqu'à présent tient tous les matches
qu'ils me reprochent
[Musique]
à jakarta après 18 heures il fait déjà
nuit redouane est arrivé au quartier de
murat bar où il a apporté ce que les
gens appellent ici l'eau traitée elle
sera utilisée pour laver les vêtements
la vaisselle pour nettoyer la maison
pour cuire la nourriture
il faut d'abord la faire bouillir ils
ont trouvé un moyen de faire monter des
bouteilles de 19 litres à tous les
étages de l'immeuble à nouveau savoir
faire de l'ère de l'anthropocène le
pêcheur centra a fait rouler l'une des
chars dans son appartement avant ils
vivaient sur le rivage mais sa maison a
été emportée en 2015 par une inondation
semprun et sa mère ont réussi à
s'échapper
je préfère ici il n'ya presque pas de
rapa de moustiques
là où on vivait avant il y avait des
inondations presque tous les ans de très
fortes inondations au cinquième étage
l'idée à l'abri des inondations et pour
une jarre d'eau il faut toujours payer
5000 roupies la livraison d'eau
ininterrompue est la chose la plus
pratique de ce nouveau logement
là où on vivait avant on devait acheter
de l'eau traitée
il fallait attendre qu'elle soit livrée
ensuite on s'est mis à aller la chercher
avec des bouteilles si l'eau n'était pas
livré on ne pouvait rien laver pendant
la journée
semprun ne sait rien sur l'affaissement
de son quartier après tout les bâtiments
n'ont pas de fissure le sol sans fond
sur une large zone et cet
affaiblissement ne peut être remarqué
qu'avec un équipement spécial ou lors
d'une inondation
la pénurie d'eau est un problème très
grave à jakarta la ville met tout en
oeuvre pour tenter de le résoudre
rapidement charaf
tout d'abord le système public
d'approvisionnement en eau doit être
développée de manière accélérée
malheureusement il n'est pas encore très
étendue pour le moment et beaucoup de
ménages doivent utiliser les eaux
souterraines avec le développement du
système d'approvisionnement en eau nous
espérons réduire l'extraction des eaux
souterraines et à terme que cette
pratique disparaisse totalement un jour
voilà l'échéance annoncée par les
autorités de jakarta
les autorités boliviennes reconnaissent
l'existence d'un problème avec le lac au
pot mais jusqu'à présent elles ont
également hésité à réagir
elle espère que le lac reviendra à la
vie pour aider à atténuer l'impact de
cette catastrophe environnementale
l'union européenne a envoyé 14 millions
d'euros à la bolivie
l'élevage de poissons a été lancée à pau
au co mais l'eau peu profonde était
d'une température trop élevée et les
poissons n'ont pas survécu
il est beaucoup plus difficile de
réparer la nature que de la détruire et
à faire tes amène terme la pollution
n'est pas la seule raison pour laquelle
cela qu'à changer le changement
climatique mondial est également en
cause
en bolivie la pollution minimes mais
certains pays polluent l'environnement
365 jours par an sans arrêt sans même se
poser la question je voudrais profiter
de ce moment pour appeler ces pays
industriels à assumer leurs
responsabilités en matière
d'environnement
à l'ère de l'anthropocène les débats
concernant le comportement
environnemental de certains pays vont
être de plus en plus dense on le voit
pas la façon dont sont prises les
décisions internationales relatives au
contrôle des émissions
c'est un nouveau facteur de la politique
internationale il deviendra de plus en
plus important au fil du temps quant aux
pays développés pays assez riche
il manifeste une réticence insolente à
faire quoi que ce soit qui irait contre
leurs intérêts à court terme
rauscher soyinka c'était le cas avec un
george w bush
c'est le cas avec donald trump
aujourd'hui ainsi les intérêts à court
terme des états unis d intérêt qui porte
sur 4 5 ans seulement chef ils
l'emportent sur les intérêts à long
terme de ces mêmes états unis laissant
sa mise en scène y en a 4 animera un bal
beau stock
ils ont peur de perdre face à une europe
qui est mieux préparé pour fabriquer par
exemple des équipements et des voitures
économes en énergie etc
alors que le stress hydrique augmente
progressivement une personne sur trois
sur la planète n'a pas accès à l'eau
potable et près de la moitié de la
population mondiale vit dans des zones
où le niveau des mers monte l'eau reste
un problème urgente
vous savez qu'en 7 milliards et demi de
personnes bientôt 8 milliards essaient
de s'entendre sur quelque chose alors
qu'ils vivent tous dans des conditions
différentes bagata i watch you mais
veulent vivre riche sans tenir compte
des conséquences de leurs actions
cela pourrait mener à de violents
conflits où tu mets conflict match sa
traque
il y aura d'abord des affrontements pour
l'eau pour la nourriture
engel sa part dr pète hines
ce sera un très grave problème les états
puissants notamment militairement
pourront faire valoir leurs droits et
défendre les intérêts de leurs citoyens
l'eau de la terre est au coeur de
nombreuses problématiques actuelles
comme à venir
l'activité humaine assure la planète un
impact qu'elle n'avait jamais eu
auparavant
l'homme est bien souvent à l'origine des
sécheresses d'inondations de pénurie en
eau ou d'excès de celle ci les exemples
du peuple au rouet de jakarta nous
rappelle que les humains ne pourront pas
changer de train dit facilement ne
pourront sûrement pas trouvé un nouveau
foyer
après tout la terre la planète de l'eau
est la seule maison que nous avons
[Musique]